people always talk about how like uh
comedians at least right they'll go on
Joe Rogan and like changes their their
career trajectory when you went on drug
and you've been on twice yeah shout out
to Brian Moses shout out to Moses I got
to get with Moses today matter of fact
did you notice like uh like just this
any sort of like spike in listenership
or like
because you went on the first time I
actually went to Austin with you yeah
uh I think Joe Rogan is like he like the
king of white people man so it's
definitely somewhere
he's up there so my white people
definitely you know start rocking with
me he might be just the king of like
everything males yeah he's like male
testosterone energy like you know Joe
Joe is my guy man so uh you know um
shout out to him and just allowing me to
come on the show you know um and I'm
about to go back on there again matter
of fact I missed jokes I'm supposed to
go to the fight with Joe but I couldn't
I couldn't make it because I'm doing all
this album stuff but uh you know Joe's
like he's you know a comedic genius you
know great podcast genius did that first
episode you guys did was four like four
hours long I could sit with Joe all day
saying the way I sit with you yeah you
know I mean I want to take you on there
with me you want to go in there please
let's go you should go on there with me
man you should go in there with me and
Brian Moses I'm down that would be
amazing you know what I'm saying I think
that we could do a five hour show you
know how many times on this podcast I've
told the story story about the day that
we met Joe Rogan and I shrooms with you
and Fit Mommy in Austin oh yeah and I
was tripping [ __ ] hard on Sixth damn
I remember that day that was like one of
the worst that was like I was [ __ ] up
bro that was a crazy and your girl kept
[ __ ] with me making wild ass [ __ ]
faces and she still had hair then I was
alone she had a little bit of hair down
here it was real short yeah she had like
the yeah yeah she's like a little pixie
cut a little something yeah something
like that that's before the ball ball
but you also went on Joe [ __ ] like right
after like they tried to cancel him and
I love how you kind of yeah yeah cause
that's my friend man you know what I'm
saying and he he [ __ ] up he made a
mistake yeah it is what it is I don't
think that he like you know I didn't
think that he like hated black people or
[ __ ] like that you know what I'm saying
because a lot of people say that [ __ ]
with Force I don't think he was saying
that [ __ ] with Force you'd have said
like and you know Dave Chappelle kick it
with the [ __ ] so how bad could he be
right I think two comedians I think like
if you look at like some comedy right
like
comedians I feel like they come from a
perspective of like nothing's off limits
nothing that's why I love Dave Chappelle
because he don't give a [ __ ] like if you
watch a Louis CK special he's he's
joking about the wildest [ __ ] the
wildest [ __ ] I love Louis CK too you
know I'm saying shout out to Louis CK
shout out to Jeff Ross oh my all my
homies in that whole comedic world man
you know could you see yourself doing
like a little like like a little
stand-up run oh hell yeah definitely man
I'm about to shout out to Chris red I
think that me and Chris red about to put
something together for sure but uh man
all my homies in comedy rest in peace
Jack night man
um shout out to Sam J I just talked to
Sam it's great I just talked to Sam
before I came in you know I feel like
they really you know you know Brian
Moses really
um catapulting me in that world man we
got to get him some new Jordans
I'm gonna take a shoe shops take them
all take them shopping periods yeah
I got you man yeah he'll be tying the
[ __ ] like he about to go
dunking he got those Team Jordans for
sure I'm getting my [ __ ] be out
here wearing a pair of Eddie Jones
maybe having the six rings elevens is
like just tied tight tied all the way to
the top to the top real goddamn shoe bed
but yeah he but Moses put me in that
world man you know I ain't look back you
know I mean um I shot a movie with the
Lucas Brothers
shout out to them I thought I forgot I
forgot we even did that wow you know
what I'm saying so uh you know that was
like a short film that we did that was
amazing
um it's just it's so many things um
media wise
so many ways that I want to you know
express myself you know I just feel like
I don't know like you know rappers
coming trying to start and become
secondary to those you know because it's
like like I said it's a you know I'm
still learning myself I'm still growing
you know I mean uh the rap is such a
huge part of my life you know I mean
I've been doing this [ __ ] since I was 20
years old and now I'm 40. so it's just
like but if you would have told me
at 20 years old
um that I was uh gonna have to wait
this long to have you know to be
to to get the respect that I want I
probably would have told you that I quit
I probably would have been like [ __ ]
that I ain't doing that you know what
I'm saying but uh
I worked at it I persevered man it took
time you know what I'm saying um lots of
lots of errors in your career too and I
never peaked I never peeked out you know
what I'm saying and I don't even think
I'm about to Peak right now I just feel
like a consistency and um
you know just being dedicated to the
craft man dedicated to being a rapper
you know what I'm saying first and not
just a
a
somebody trying to catch a wave you know
I mean or catch a record like you know I
never cared about that you know as long
as people always said off Freddie Gibbs
one of the best rappers
that's all that really mattered to me
you know I'm saying like you know when
you gave me that respect you know I
ain't want to fizzle out I ain't wanna
you know cause
a lot of guys come in the game and they
have
big records early you know and you know
they probably not around right now you
know I mean or probably can't get
nothing going right now they probably
put their record out and they're just
like you know what I'm saying and this
one and these guys I got Platinum hits